and fair economy that means trade trade
with the rest of the world is more
important than ever for Europe
supporting 36 million jobs across Europe
mm more than in 2000 European exports
support almost 20 million jobs outside
European Union including 1 millions of
jobs in the United States alone we have
launched a month ago a new alliance for
sustainable investment and jobs with
Africa to have boost trade between our
two continents and create up to 10
million jobs in Africa in the next five
years
don't underestimate the dimension of our
neighbourhood with Africa Africa is
becoming more and more important and
will be always on the side of our
African friends of course we have to
develop the rules we have adopted years
ago we are on our way to reform the
World Trade Organization we are doing
this in close cooperation with the
United States of America when it comes
to climate change will repeat president
today and myself our commitment to stick
to the agreement we have concluded years
ago in Paris so thank you for to the
Argentinian government and its president
we are the meeting with yesterday
morning
for the way they are organizing in the
best conditions possible this two-day
speak thank you President Assad a few
words to what President Juncker has said
if this is a difficult moment for
international cooperation I would like
to appeal to the leaders to use this
summit including their bilateral and
informal exchanges to seriously discuss
real issues such as trade was the tragic
situation in Syria and Yemen
and the Russian aggression in Ukraine I
see no reason why the g20 leaders
shouldn't have a meaningful discussion
about solving these problems especially
because all the instruments lie in their
hands the only condition is a goodwill
we also cannot underestimate other
issues which remain difficult for some
leaders such as human rights freedom of
press and basic safety of journalists it
is our obligation as the EU to take this
opportunity and press our partners to
respect these basic principles many
leaders will certainly have questions
about brexit therefore let me say this
the European Union has just agreed an
orderly divorce with the United Kingdom
a few days before the vote in the House
of Commons it is becoming more and more
clear that this view is the best
possible in fact the only possible one
if this deal is rejected in the Commons
we are left with as was already stressed
a few weeks ago by Prime Minister may
and alternative No Deal
oh no break it at home I want to
reassure you that the EU is prepared for
every scenario thank you we can now
switch to your questions Rebecca mostly
avec you negotiate of which your
question is from the newspaper the soir
question to president Younker regarding
the EU us discussions on on on trade and
the non imposition so far of tariffs on
cars do you expect to have direct talks
with President Trump and don't you fear
that
don't you fear turnin in the events in
this issue particularly since the
announcement of General Motors to close
the plants in in the US
and since you I'm asking you about this
secondary question since you had this
very successful meeting in July with
President Trump successful because
results are lasting till today which is
quite as a success with this president
would you have an advice to to him and
to president Qi for the over important
meeting tomorrow thank you
yes I had the thought meeting exchange
of views with US president the other day
on the 11th of November in Paris I have
noticed with not happiness but with a
certain degree of satisfaction that
nothing has changed between US and
European Union since our last meeting by
the end of July in Washington I will
find in the cause of today and in the
margins of the meeting an opportunity to
weaken form this mutable commitment that
we have concluded back in in July and we
are discussing these issues with our
American friends like European Union
which is a strong one which is the
biggest internal market of the world and
I have good news for the American
president because according to our
commitments back in July the export from
liquefied natural gas from us into the
European Union has increased by 52% and
imports on European side of soybeans by
one with 100% which is clearly showing
that we are sticking to our commitments
and I the one who could give advice to
the US president and to the Chinese
president yes but I will do it
when
Gusti Milton okay then I had German
press agency yes Great Scott unguarded
from the German press agency DPA the
European Union announced that it will
act appropriately to the use of force by
Russia in the Sea of Azov what what does
it mean an appropriate reaction is it
possible to have an appropriate we
actually without new sanctions if
there's no de-escalation and the next
week's the distillation in the Sea of
Azov is a cause of of grave concern to
us and of course Russia's use of force
against Ukrainian ships this totally
unacceptable Europe this is what I would
like to underline the Europe is united
in support to Ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity this is why I am
sure that they you will roll over the
sanctions against Russia in December yes
next question I had Scalia question for
president you care in these days also
continue the negotiation on an Italian
budget you are gonna meet Prime Minister
country today just wanted to know if do
you think there is still the possibility
to avoid the excessive deficit procedure
of course that base excessive deficit
procedure and in this be of what kind of
effort do you think is necessary from
the Italian side an important cut on the
deficit and when it's the important more
than 0.2 what were you expecting I will
have a meeting with Jada piccante in the
course of the day or tomorrow I don't
know exactly when it will happen
I had the conservative meeting with the
Italian Prime Minister last Saturday in
Brussels
we made some progress we are not at war
with Italy I want Italy to be the Italy
Italy always was inspiring Europe not
turning its back to Europe the
atmosphere is good we are making
progress and we should not dramatize
this issue we are with Italy Italy is
with us this concludes our press
conference thank you very much